if you were turned into a magical girl
out of nowhere what would you do this
popular game is turning everyone's
dreams into reality but it's hiding a
deadly secret i'm going to break down
the mistakes made what you should do and
how to beat the death game in magical
girl raising project this innocent girl
is about to be trapped in a fight for
her life kayuki here is your everyday
teenager and she loves magical girls
taking the bus with her friends they
asked koyuki if she believes the recent
magical girl sightings are real they
flick through the news seeing stories of
magical girls helping civilians out in
all kinds of situations the friends
realize that koyuki really likes magical
girls so they introduce her to a new
game called magical girl racing project
kayuki admits though that she's already
on the game and she loves to play it
however this cute little game is about
to turn into something much more
sinister that night she plays the game
and decides to stop when her mom calls
her for dinner she tries to quit but she
finds out that there's a secret event
happening right now the game's mascot
fob tells her that he's been following
her progress throughout the game and has
decided to appoint her as a real-life
magical girl a button is then shown on
the screen and koyuki decides to press
it suddenly she begins her
transformation into the same magical
girl she plays in the game snow white
realizing that her lifelong dreams have
just come true she jumps in joy and hits
the roof fav informs her that her
physical abilities have been increased
to extreme levels he gives her a magical
phone and tells her that there are 15
other magical girls in the city each
with unique abilities her ability is to
hear the thoughts of those in trouble
their goal is to collect as many magical
candies as possible showing how many
people they've helped he also tells her
that no matter what she does no
civilians will be able to interact or
see her okay we've just been given a
gift from the gods and the possibilities
are endless we can do whatever we want
go wherever we like and no one can tell
us otherwise at least for now the first
thing i would do is to try to steal a
whole lot of money because i want to
live a nice and easy life you know what
i mean i would not be surprised if some
of them haven't already done this we're
magical girls we don't really have to
play by the law do we i would be pretty
darn excited but also pretty darn
careful with what's going on remember
kids if you're signing a contract it's
always important to read the fine print
devil's in the details we've completely
signed our life away to a low quality
mobile game and we have no idea what the
reputation of this game company is like
in fact it might do us some good to
google the company before making such a
life-changing agreement don't you think
regardless though of the contractual
obligations we've already signed off and
now we're locked into the magical girl
life for good and it might not end being
as sweet as it is right now not only are
we going out way past our bedtime we
still got to attend school and do all of
that normal day-to-day crap we also need
to consider what kind of effects this is
going to have on our mental health
staying up every single night it might
be cool being a magical girl right now
but what happens when we grow up to have
kids and other adult obligations it
might be a little bit of a pain in the
ass to go stop crime at three in the
morning when you gotta wake up at six
feed the kids take out the garbage and
then go to work a week later fav tells
her that she should meet up with the
other magical girls and gives her the
ability to enter a chat room with others
like her she enters the room and is
greeted by the other magical girls who
congratulate kuyuki on getting the
highest amount of magical candies for
this week koyuki is flattered but she's
about to find out that these new friends
are going to want her dead very soon she
leaves the chat room and is given a
message to meet one of the magical girls
at a nearby tower she travels to the
destination and flies to the top of the
tower to see another girl and this
mysterious girl introduces herself as la
puselle and offers to introduce her to
the duties of being a magical girl she
tells kayuki that each magical girl has
a different district of the city that
they must protect and that's when this
pair of magical girls pass by to meet
koyuki they introduce themselves as the
outgoing top speed and the quiet but
cool ripple suddenly la puselle reveals
that she's actually a guy
but moving on and that he's known koyuki
for a while since they both went to the
same elementary school and both loved
the same game a few days passed by and
fav announces that he'll be cutting in
half the amount of magical girls as the
man of the city can't handle having 15
magical girls all at once and he tells
the girls that week by week the magical
girls with the least amount of candies
will be cut until only eight remain the
week after the girls wait in the chat
room to say who got the highest amount
of magical candies for the week the
winner is announced as koyuki and the
loser is announced as this light-hearted
girl and she admits that she might have
been spending too much time in the chat
room and says goodbye to the rest of the
girls suddenly a message says that that
girl has been deleted the real-life
version of her size as she realizes that
the fun is over fav tells her that she
still has until midnight to use her
magical girl abilities and that's when
she decides to dip into the fantasy
world for one last time looking over a
little girl watching a princess roll by
back in the real world her mother walks
in to see how she's doing and she tries
waking her daughter up but she's shocked
to find out that her daughter is dead
the night after kaiyuki and la puselle
sit around wondering how that girl is
doing and they get a call from this holy
girl sister nana and this ninja girl
went to prison who informs her that that
girl has died and every girl who loses
their magical abilities will follow the
same fate uh okay holy [ __ ] what
everyone thought was an innocent game
meant to help the citizens of this city
has made a turn for the worse now
everyone here could be an enemy and
we'll have to go from saving citizens to
get candies to saving ourselves now i
know power in numbers is an important
thing yes and we have our trustworthy
buddy la puselle who seems really
determined to protect us no matter what
and his sword looks like he can take out
our enemies pretty dang easily however
we need to consider the rules of this
game and how we can abuse them to her
advantage it's pretty damn obvious that
this magical candy thing is all a ploy
to get us to fight being able to
transfer between other magical girls
makes no sense and helping out civilians
is not the most efficient way to stay
alive if i were kuyuki since we know
that there are 14 other girls still
alive and with the other mystery girl
that hasn't come out of hiding yet the
most efficient way to satisfy the
demands that fav has given us is to join
up with seven other girls with a group
of eight we'll take out the other six
and destroy the mystery girl whenever
she shows up and of course this is
easier said than done i know considering
that some girls already have paired up
and might have relations that go beyond
the game like me and la pacelle now
there is another option that might be a
bit risky we know that every single
magical girl in this game also exists in
the real world and that means that if
they die in the real world well what
happens folks they die in the game too
we all know that these girls live within
the same city or at least pretty damn
close to it if we found a way to track
these girls in the real world and it's
not that hard through social media we
could follow them around during the day
and try to take them out in the real
world while this might seem like a great
idea on paper this will also probably
lead us to getting arrested for murder
so this option is definitely more of a
last ditch idea all the girls enter the
chat room to hear the announcement fav
is going to make the doll tells them the
truth if they come up short with their
magical candies or drop out of the game
they'll die in real life koyugi and
lapuzel said at the top of the tower
wondering who the next seven to die are
going to be she begins crying and la
pusal promises to protect her no matter
what that's when they get a notice
informing them that they can transfer
magical candies amongst one another
meanwhile another group of magical girls
sit listening to their leader and she
tells them that this notice isn't meant
to make sure everyone has equal candies
rather it means that they need to kill
and steal from whoever has the most
candies koyuki and la puselle read that
a 16th girl will soon be revealed and
they're excited to see who she is when
suddenly these two twins attack them on
site and la busell chases them down to a
nearby shipyard and the twins demand
that she hand over her candies pissed
off la puselle attacks the twins and
tells them to run off before she kills
them however the twins have a plan up
their sleeves and they activate a trap
opening the ground below lapu cell and
trapping her inside meanwhile the leader
and swim swim ambush koyuki and tell her
their true intentions they're going to
kill her and they lured her best friend
far away to make it easy suddenly the
leader casts a spell on her which
freezes her completely and tells swim
swim to drain the girl of all of her
candies back at the shipyard la pusalle
reveals that she was never trapped and
jumps out of the pit to attack the twins
and she noticed them transformed into an
eagle and begins to fly away that's when
she realizes that the entire thing was a
ploy to distract her from the tower
lapisel follows the twins and watches as
swim swim drains koyuki of her candies
angered she increases the size of her
sword and bangs the tower causing
everyone on top of it to fall off and
lapisel catches koyuki and tells her
that they need to get the candies back
the rankings will be released today and
she'll be put in last place okay la
puselle is a massive bro and we should
be doing whatever we can to save our own
butts she's offering to help us out and
we should be taking whatever help that
we can get if i was koyuki i need to be
very aware of the fact that i basically
have zero combat abilities and him
totally useless not only that we're
facing absolute killers that can easily
hunt us down and murder us in brutal
fashion our first order of business is
to get our candies back if we don't
we'll die at this point it might be our
best bet to half the amount of candies
that we have with la puselle that way we
don't have to deal with that group of
evil girls just yet and we might have
just enough to beat out of some other
schmuck who's not been gathering as much
candies as everyone else once this whole
candy business is over and done with our
next priority should be to learn some
fighting moves from our dear old friend
here he seems to know a lot about combat
and has skills with weapons which seems
to be pretty darn used judging by what
just happened between us and the evil
magical girls also since we can't be
seen by regular citizens it might be
worth trying to head over to one of the
many gun stores available in japan and
borrow whatever heavy artillery guns we
can find we don't know how effective
guns can be against magical girls yet
but it's a hell of a lot better than
being completely defenseless and i say
steal some guns because good luck trying
to get one legally from those bad boys
in the sunrise kingdom without any
hassle back at the hideout swim swim
checks to see that she's gained around 2
000 candies from koyuki the leader tells
them that she's not going to split the
candies equally rather she'll give 1 000
to herself 500 to swim swim and the
remaining 500 to the other three girls
she calls the others idiots for nearly
ruining the plan and checks the weekly
rankings to see that she has been ranked
the lowest out of the girl as she lays
in a pool of her own blood the twins
celebrate realizing that their plan
worked swim swim transferred the stolen
candies to this dog loving girl tama
equalling 25 000 stolen candies and
swimsuit reveals that koyuki has 50 000
but decided to play nice and only steal
half swimsuim hides the body of the real
life leader while appointing herself as
the new leader of the group meanwhile
ripple and top speed meet with sister
nana who suggests that they put an end
to this senseless violence the magical
girl called calamity mary enjoys a drink
with this robot here commenting that
she's earning candies by doing both good
and bad deeds the robot tells her that
she needs to go see sister nana and help
her out with a certain problem she meets
with both sister nana and winter prison
telling them that she has some special
connections with the admins of the
server but it's going to cost money the
sister hands it over but winter prison
isn't too sure that the robot is
completely truthful they receive a text
from wild cranberry asking to meet at a
nearby quarry and head there instantly
there they meet up and sister nana tells
the girl that they need to put a stop to
the other magical girls stealing candies
and harming each other wild cranberry
tells her that she has some other things
in mind and tells sister nada to stop
preaching and ruining the game hearing
this winter prison stands in front of
the sister and wild cranberry attacks
them they fight it out and winter prison
quickly realizes that she's no match for
the evil magical girl she wrecks stone
walls around her to position her to trap
her and grab sister nana running away
wild cranberry easily gets out of the
trap and watches as the two barely make
it out alive fav pops up and questions
why she didn't kill them but she admits
that winter prison is a worthy opponent
and that they'll meet again sometime
soon later that night the injured girls
meet up with the 16th contestant hard
gore alice sister nana tells her that
it's up to them to stop the fighting and
mentions that koyuki was attacked for
having the most candies she reveals her
location and hardcore alice instantly
leaves to go find her okay if i were
sister nana i would probably take the
time to reassess my situation and maybe
call it a day call it quits while she is
doing something very admirable and very
noble in the death game that is full of
liars cheaters and tricksters you're
either gonna be a scumbag and live or
you're gonna die now as nana our special
ability is to draw the full potential of
our loved one's power and that special
person is winter prison out of all the
magical girls in the game we're the only
two people that are pretty much a combo
deal just like burger and fries mmm
delicious winter prison's special
ability is to make walls out of nowhere
and combined with the nana's abilities
we should be able to make enough walls
to trap the entire city however we don't
need to forget about all of our heroic
ideals it's just a matter of finding
those who share the same ideas as us and
combining our forces to take the magical
girls who are pure evil out and who else
could be the perfect fit for the job
other than our very own kuyuki and la
poucelle meanwhile koyuki and lafusel
said their goodbyes for the night that's
when la puselle looks behind her to see
wild cranberry waiting for her this time
one-on-one they move to the dockyards to
make sure no civilians get injured and
battle it out la paselle tries to get at
her but wild cranberry is too much the
evil magical girl knees her off of the
building and vows to kill her she leaves
her in a pool of her own blood but is
about to land the final blow when la
pacelle just barely dodges grabbing her
sword and she runs at the evil girl
knowing that she won't survive in the
chat room bob notices that only two
magical girls have shown up to hear the
results and she tells the girls that the
game has added five new items all with
unique abilities however there's only
one of each secondly she announces that
la puselle is dead due to an accident
since someone has already died the
lowest ranked magical girl is saved from
elimination this week later fav tries
advertising one of the items to kayuki
who declines and says that she's not
going to fight anymore fav mentions that
her friend may have been killed by
another magical girl and that these
items may help her fight off any
incoming enemies fob also tells her that
these items don't cost any money however
they do take off years of your life the
more powerful they are the more years
they take off kayoki clicks on the sword
but realizes that it along with every
other item has been already bought
suddenly hardcore alice finds her
sitting all by herself and she walks
towards the helpless girl when the robot
comes out of nowhere and brutally kills
her the robot admits that she's here to
kill her as well but the robot ends up
being brutally murdered just like alice
okay we've just missed a golden
opportunity looking at each individual
item i would say it would be time for us
to take the risk and do whatever it
takes to beat this game instead of
waiting around like koyuki did fav has
tricked us many times before we know but
there's no way for that little snot to
prove that all of these items can take
years off of our life especially if we
win the game we have to question
everything that this little turd says no
matter how ridiculous it may seem if it
were me i would have taken every single
gosh darn weapon on this list our only
goal is to beat this death game and make
it out alive so even if i have to
sacrifice a few decades off of my life
eh i'm young i have plenty more decades
left to spare i shouldn't have to worry
about it after i make it out of the
death game alive thinking about it more
carefully though how can vav predict how
many years of life we have left in the
first place at this point it might have
the answer to the meaning of life itself
by using some of these weapons for
example the invisibility cloak which
takes 25 years off of our life we can
essentially cheat the game and hide away
forever until the other magical girls
take themselves out not only that as far
as we know we should be able to use the
cloak with other people meaning we can
protect and hide whoever else wants to
join the cloak gang if we put all the
numbers together that would equate to 49
years of life considering that we're
still in school and japanese people live
to be pretty dang old there's a very
good chance that we'll be decades from
dying even after purchasing the items
koyuki wakes up with a keychain on her
hand and she's confused and fav suggests
that she might have picked it up the
night before fav mentions that hard gore
alice was the last person to have it and
koyuki realizes that everything that she
experienced wasn't a simple nightmare it
was real and that's when she gets a text
from sister nana asking to meet at a
secluded location meanwhile on the chat
room fav announces that the robot has
died meaning that there won't be a loser
eliminated from this week's rankings
koyuki meets up with sister nana and not
a consulser about la puselle's death
they agree to work together so they can
stop the mindless deaths but that's when
koyuki notices hardcore alice standing
in the distance shocked alice agrees to
work with them as well and sister nana
tells them that she'll be going off to
meet with more magical girls koyuki runs
out of the warehouse but is creepily
followed by alice she offers her the
keychain saying that it belongs to
koyuki and she explains that she can
regrow parts of her body meaning that
she wasn't killed the other night her
head was chopped off but she regrew it
and is back to normal dang we need to
watch out for this girl if being able to
make walls hear people's thoughts and
make your own sword increase inside
exponentially wasn't crazy enough
hardcore alice here has just changed the
game big time this little girl has the
lottery with her ability she can't be
killed which means the only way we can
lose the game is by having the least
amount of points judging by how
depressed she looks she might not
realize how lucky she is especially
compared to koyuki's crappy ability if
anything the rest of the contestants
should look to make a truce with this
girl asap by stopping the killings for
at least one week to go collect some
candies but we know that's never going
to happen sister nana confronts calamity
mary saying that she's been using magic
to commit crimes which is against the
magical girl code of conduct mary tells
her to not stand in her way and fires a
gun at nana winter prison erects a
massive wall to protect them and runs
away from mary with nana in her arms
they travel to swim swim's hideout where
sister nana thanks her for sending the
stolen candies she took from the leader
without a response swim swim paces
forward and sends a robotic version of
sister nana to attack the innocent girls
suddenly winter prison is stabbed by
robot nana and they reveal themselves to
be the twins in disguise however winter
prison isn't as hurt as the evil magical
girls thought and she erects a few
massive walls to trap the girls in
that's when winter prison kills one of
the twins and jumps out of the trap to
take out the other but is too late she
slashed by swim swim which kills her on
the spot meanwhile ripple and top speed
wait around on a rooftop to meet up with
calamity mary suddenly they're shot at
and realized that mary is out to kill
them they hop onto ripple's broomstick
and ride off avoiding her gunshots the
human version of koyuki watches from
outside of her window as they fight it
out civilians are dying left and right
and mary is causing havoc in the city
koyuki turns back into a magical girl
and is joined by alice who promises to
help her
hell yeah if alice isn't lying to us for
some reason that would suck then we've
essentially beaten the game if i were
koyuki i'd be the happiest magical girl
alive right now and i'd also avoid
getting involved in this massive war
going on outside of my house using my
abilities i should be able to read
calamity mary's mind to find out that
she's truly absolutely nuts and that
she's out to kill whoever stands in her
way whether that be civilians or magical
girls her finesse with weapons is enough
to take out anyone from miles away and
that means she's a dangerous individual
which we have no chance fighting against
since however alice seems to be indebted
to us i'd simply let her go and take
care of business she'll be able to take
whatever punishment comes her way and
that means she's a valuable asset to us
now that our trusty love purcell is dead
in the water mary continues shooting
bullets at ripple and top speed trying
to kill them both ripple decides to take
matters into her own hands and jumps off
the broomstick to face her mono amano
and they fight it out and accidentally
ripple steps onto a landmine suddenly
mary whips out grenades and nearly kills
the girl luckily top speed catches her
on the broomstick and saves her life
they travel back to the roof and send
the broomstick flying through the
building trying it one more time they
get caught by mary's sniper rifle
sending them flying into a nearby
warehouse now they realize that they
need to face her head-on and kill her
now or else they'll be hunted for the
rest of the game they launch a surprise
attack throwing a shuriken into the
girl's head and killing calamity mary
for good they give each other a hug but
ripple sees blood on her hands shocked
she looks over top speed shoulder to see
swim swim who just brutally murdered her
best friend the girl becomes enraged and
attacks swim swim with all of her power
however the pink-haired girl is too
strong and disappears into the building
she looks over at top speed to see her
human form appear meaning she's dead and
she realizes that in her human form top
speed was pregnant and wanted to survive
the game six more months to give birth
meanwhile the twins arrive to help out
the mess left by calamity mary suddenly
she throws an ax into alice's face and
koyuki realizes that she's not here to
help and that's when she hears the
thoughts of another girl and listens in
to hear another girl about to attack the
twin scolds her for being caught and
tama disappears into the ground back in
the real world the news reports on the
massive amount of destruction caused by
the magical girls but they have no idea
where it came from sister nada decides
to call it quits becoming another victim
of the death game fav announces that a
grand total of five magical girls have
died meaning that seven girls remain and
the game should be over however he has
another announcement to make and he
needs to cut in half the amount of
magical girls again this time to four
that night koyuki and alice meet up at
the beach and she thanks the girl for
helping her out and they hear the news
from phot that only four girls will be
allowed to survive hearing this koyuki
freaks out and demands that they stop
the killing running away out of anger
okay at this point koyuki and the
magical girl should realize that this
game is pure evil not only have all the
girls been brutally killing each other
causing utter destruction to the city
and a lifetime of therapy but pulling a
bait-in switch and asking us to keep on
playing games means that we can't trust
this game at all if i was koyuki i would
try to make the other girls call it
quits of the whole killing business we
know that fob and whoever else is behind
the raising project isn't telling the
truth and this game is going to likely
get us all killed in the end now what
can we do to get out of this mess there
are four of us left and both alice and
ripple are on our side swim swimsuit
looks like she's hopeless so we should
kill her to make sure that she doesn't
try to mess with us anymore even though
she's an absolute beast it's three
against one and there's a very good
chance that we can beat her out of the
remaining three magical girls she seems
to be the type to make a pact and then
backstab us and it's in our best
interest to take out any possible loose
strengths so that we can focus on the
task at hand we need to escape this game
no matter what it takes what we should
do is to look into the previous deaths
of the other magical girls specifically
those who died without any external
circumstances being involved like that
girl and see what caused them to die if
we go full on private investigator mode
we should also be able to find some news
on what caused certain magical girls
like herself to bite the dust from there
we might be able to decipher a way to
quit the game and go back to our normal
lives forgetting everything that
happened here hell at some point it
might be in our best interest to take a
visit to the local police station and
tell them what's going on while they
might think us crazy there shouldn't be
anything stopping us from transforming
right in front of them and proving what
we're saying is true after that we could
spread the news to the entire world and
get everyone involved in figuring out a
way to release us from this disturbing
game responsible for killing innocent
people the next day alice is attacked
while in human form and she runs to a
nearby alleyway to transform but is
finished off by swim swim in her final
breath she remembers that she needs to
give back the keychain suddenly kayuki
realizes something is off when she gets
home from school and she turns into a
magical girl and jumps across the city
to see the crowd of bystanders standing
around an empty coat she overhears what
they're saying and finds herself in the
alleyway where alice is lying in her
human form she thanks kayuki for all
that she's done and gives her the
keychain before she dies that night swim
swim and her gang catch a plan to ambush
wild cranberry swim swim enters her
house to find it completely empty while
cranberry here is walking outside she
knows exactly what's going on and grabs
a rock throwing it onto the ground to
reveal the twins now dead tama
apologizes to swim swim for messing up
and they walk over to see the twins
lifeless body swim swim tries to
surprise attack cranberry but she dodges
and causes a massive explosion
destroying all of the surrounding trees
she goes to finish her off but is
surprised to see that her human form is
a child tama comes from behind hitting
her with a magic item suddenly cranberry
blows up and slumps to the ground tama
runs over to swim swim's human form and
she gets back up showing little to no
injuries she transforms back into a
magical girl and chops thomas head off
killing the innocent girl she mutters to
herself that she can't let her real
identity be known that night fav
announces the weekly rankings this time
four girls have been killed so the
number of magical candies don't matter
anymore and the game is essentially over
with three girls remaining in her human
form koyuki receives a text from ripple
and they meet up at a nearby tower and
ripple asks her for any information
about swim swim kayuki is confused since
the game is over but ripple vows to take
revenge for the death of her friend
pfaff pops up and warns the girl to be
scared of swim swim everyone who's tried
to mess with her has died but he
mentions that the mass murderer has one
weakness light and sound bob mentions
that the amount of magical girls might
have been reduced to two and urges
ripple to get her revenge back at her
place koyuki tells fob that she wants to
quit being a magical girl fab is shocked
and says that she's a valuable candidate
for having survived so long fav reveals
that the entire thing is a recruitment
project picking one of the magical girls
to become a member of the world of magic
this allows them to become a full-time a
magical girl or become a master like fav
and conduct further magical girl raising
projects fav reveals that wild cranberry
was a master but was killed by swim swim
now that the other two girls are
fighting all kuyuki has to do is wait
until they kill each other to win the
game okay now while i know it might seem
like a really bad idea to listen to the
very person that got us into this mess
agreeing with vov right now might be a
good idea while the magical girl raising
project may be very sweet twisted
demented and responsible for killing
some of our very good friends it is
going to lead us to our dream of
becoming a full-time magical girl now we
can do whatever we want for the rest of
our lives whether that be to travel to
different countries eat nice food we've
always dreamt about and never spend
another day in school ever again because
school sucks or we can become the master
and make sure that this deadly cycle of
death games never happens again it's
something to consider since we've gone
through a ridiculous amount of trials
and tribulations to get to this point
there's no turning back even if we
decide to team up with the other magical
girls and try to put an end to these
games if we become a master we can make
sure that the future games and
participants aren't as deadly as the
ones before all we have to do is scope
out the magical girls that aren't crazy
children like swimswim and perhaps by
using a better selection process than a
simple video game hearing this koyuki
turns into a magical girl and breaks her
phone stopping all communication with
fav she rushes over to stop them from
fighting but she's too late and she
arrives to see the human form of swim
swim impaled on the ground and looks
over to find that ripple is also dead
bob pops up again congratulating her for
surviving without fighting once and she
attempts to break the device that fab is
popping out of but vav tells her that
it's impossible suddenly she looks up to
find that ripple is still alive she goes
over to fov and breaks the ai with her
sight six months later koyuki's friends
discuss how popular the town has become
since all the strange events began
popping up and they talk about the
magical girl raising project being
deleted but notice that there are still
supposed sightings on the news seeing
this reminds them of koyuki and they
wonder what happened to their good
friend after all this time and if you
want to get out of this death game
filled with magical girls don't forget
to like comment subscribe and check out
the how to be playlist down below